volumetrics are a great crutch for
drowning your scene and enough fog to
hide all the lack of detail because it
can't be considered low effort if it's
an abstract film like aesthetic mood
piece thing even if your scene looks
like garbage without it but hey that's
not going to stop me from using it so
I'm going to start off with a real quick
rundown of all the volumetric settings
the most important probably being Max
bounces under light paths this will give
you more detailed and realistic fog but
it's at the cost of increasing your
render Times by quite a bit step rate is
effectively the resolution of the voils
that make up the volume in this case a
lower value will give a better result
but you're probably not going to notice
much of a difference unless you're using
a texture with your
volume in the material tab check the
homogeneous button if you're not using
textures theoretically this makes it
render Faster by telling blender that
your volume is all one same density but
recent versions do this automatically so
you can just click this button if you
feel like it sampling is used for how
you want to light your volume and
interpolation is more used for smoke
simulations unchecking some of the
visibilities can improve render times
especially with jadow but this may
impact a lot of how your lighting
interacts with the volume so there's
four nodes you can plug into the
material output principled volume volume
absorption volume scatter and emission
and as much as people use principled
bsdf for everything I wouldn't really
suggest using principled volume cuz it
has a lot of settings that you won't
really ever use and missing a lot of the
settings that you should be using so
volume absorption by itself is typically
invisible until you start to add a color
to it how it works is a little confusing
because the naming is a bit backwards
compared to how it actually functions
what it does is absorb all light colors
except to the color it's set to so if
it's green it'll absorb red and blue
light and only let green pass through
and this is why when it's set to White
all the lights allowed to pass through
and when it's set to Black no light is
so by itself this can be really useful
for composition to remove certain colors
of light from specific areas or to just
block light entirely without anything
visually in the way volume scattering is
where we get the fog effect and if you
change the color of it you might think
that it's behaving weirdly but what's
Happening Here is we're telling it to
scatter only the red light and by doing
that we're allowing green and blue to
pass through unscattered creating C this
combined with colored lights can allow
certain lights to be scattered and other
lights to be passed through but a much
easier method is just to go to the
lights Ray visibility settings and turn
off volume scattering so overall
changing the scattering color is a bit
of a niche use case what you should
tweak is the anistropy value how this
works is it affects the direction light
is scattered through the volume so a
value of1 means all the light's going to
be reflected backwards value of zero
means it's going to be scattered in all
directions equally and a value of one
means it's going to be reflected
forwards and with a simple setup like
this you can take advantage of using
both directions at the same
time the volume scattering node also has
five different options for how it'll
scatter the light each one was built
with a specific use case in mind and
they all have their own settings but for
the most part you can just use whichever
one looks the best in your scene because
none of them should really render faster
than the others it is worth looking
through all of them though and tweaking
with the settings depending on your
lighting and size of the
[Music]
volume emissions pretty straightforward
it'll make your volume glow just like
how it would on a Surface so then by
plugging in some textures you can make
some procedural 3D glowing effects
[Music]
since volumes have their own output you
can mix them with any translucent or
transparent Shader you plug into the
surface output pairing this with a glass
Shader is a really easy way to make
fogged glass or murky
water and of course all the normal
settings still apply so you can make
some neat effects with
[Music]
this now the biggest downside of using
volume metrics is they can be really
expensive to render but here's a method
that can make them almost instantaneous
the first thing you need to do is
disable most of the rid visibilities
especially
Shadows depending on your scene it might
change your lighting a bit so you can go
back and tweak
that next we're going to move the volume
object into its own collection and to
make things easier I'm going to move
everything else into another
collection then go into the filters of
the outliner and make sure you have hold
out and indirect lighting
enabled from here disable the volume
collection you just made using this
checkbox and we're going to going to
make a new view layer with copied
settings now while we're on this new
view layer reenable the volume
collection and then turn on hold out and
indirect for everything else your scene
should look something like this or this
depending on what your volumetric setup
is then the most important step is to go
to the override section and the view
layer Tab and set the sample size to
something very low if we render out the
image it might look like there's no
volume metrics but what we need to do is
go to the compositor and duplicate this
rendered layer input then we're going to
switch it over to the volume layer and
we should have two images one without
volumetric and one that's only
volumetrics all we have to do is add the
two layers together and it should look
almost identical to the original image
but of course you can mix these two
layers in any way that looks the best
once again everything in this video is
going to be available for download in
the description so check that out if
you're interested
[Music]